han sido tres explosiones tres misiles
según el alcalde del ibi que han
impactado muy cerca donde nos
encontramos el centro de la capital
apenas cuatro kilómetros hacia el este
hemos escuchado las sirenas antiaéreas y
después hemos visto una columna de humo
negro densa ya la pueden ver en toda esa
zona de momento el alcalde está pidiendo
a la población que por favor no
abandonen los refugios porque hay una
alerta de que un segundo ataque se puede
producir no tenemos cifras de víctimas
mortales o de heridos en un principio se
pensaba que se había atacado la torre de
televisión pero está intacta lo cierto
es que en esa zona este hay un centro
industrial con empresas y también
depósitos de gasolina este ataque se
produce horas después de que rusia
informará de que prácticamente la
primera fase de la operación especial
estaba terminada y de que se iban a
centrar en asegurar el este del país en
la región del donbass